Speaker 1: All right.
We are going to do a deep dove into the bowels
of the Republican Party, and we are going
to see that through the lens of a completely
deranged and demented speech given by the
former president Donald Trump in Phenix, Arizona,
over the weekend.
The context of this speech was that it was
one of these turning point USA that's that
college Republican group.
It was a turning point USA event in Phenix
in support of the election audits or audits,
as some call them, which some Republicans
still believe are imminently going to lead
to the reinstatement of Donald Trump.
Now, none of that is going to happen.
It's hard to even call the audit an audit,
but we learned so much from this speech about
the state of the average Republican voter.
So let's get right into it.
First of all, just the introduction for Donald
Trump is beyond parody.
Satire is dead.
Trump coming out to dubstep, mixed in with
that lame country song that we're supposed
to pretend that a rich guy from Queens actually
likes.
Take a look at this.
Unidentified: Do you miss it?
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome the president
of the United States of America, Donald Trump.
Be an American.
Speaker 1: OK, so you get it completely beyond
parody, unable to be satire, putting Saturday
Night Live completely out of business.
But the content, the content was a mix of
lies.
Yes, delusions, of course.
And also just completely unintelligible statements.
In this clip, Trump refers to the authors
of the audit.
I assume he means the auditors.
He also, instead of talking about affidavits,
he seems to say, Aferdita, it's all weird,
Speaker 2: but we can't let this happen yet.
This is only the beginning of the irregularities
the Arizona audit is uncovering.
The authors and the auditors have collected
a sworn affidavit stating so.
Speaker 1: The auditors have uncovered the
authors and the authors found affidavits.
So, you know, that seems to be listen, if
you want a predictor as to whether these audits
will have an impact, the fact that Trump says
that they are authors finding affidavits,
it's all not good.
It's all not good.
And then maybe in the most bizarre moment
of the entire speech, Donald Trump repeating
the word rooters more than 10 times in 36
seconds.
I challenge you to prove that Trump even knows
what a router is.
Speaker 2: The county has, for whatever reason,
also refused to produce the network routers.
We want the routers, Sunny, Wendy, we got
to get those routers, plays the routers.
Come on, Charlie.
We can get those routers, those routers.
You know what?
We're so beyond the routers, there's so many
fraudulent votes.
Were that
Speaker 1: are we because you don't sound
like you're beyond them
Speaker 2: threat.
But if you got those routers, what that will
show and they don't want to give up the routers,
they don't want to give them, they are fighting
like hell.
Why are these commissioners fighting not to
give the routers?
How simple could it be that will tell the
truth?
Speaker 1: So that's very strange.
Something really weird going on there, almost
like Trump falling into some kind of linguistic
black hole where he just can't keep he can't
stop repeating the same word.
And then we go from confusion to just lies.
Trump says that the real big lie.
Is that Joe Biden won, in other words, the
lie being told is Biden won the truth, as
Trump sees it, is he actually was the winner
in November.
Now, nine months ago,
Speaker 2: the big lie, they call it, you
know, what's the big lie?
The opposite is the big lie.
The election was the big lie.
And I've got to tell you, I've got to say
this.
I've never said it before, but I've always
thought it.
Oh, if I lost the election, I'm OK with it.
I'm OK with it.
Seriously, if we lost the election, we lose
an election.
I go home, I'll start building buildings.
I'll do something.
I'll keep myself busy.
Speaker 1: Now, this is funny because he did
lose and he promised before, if I lose, you
won't see me again.
And yet here he is in like speech number five
or six since losing the election.
But he just continue.
His argument is I didn't actually lose.
Speaker 2: But you know what?
If we lost the election, we know when we lose,
you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there's that.
And then Trump just continuing with this stuff.
Let's look at one more of these.
Speaker 2: If I lost this election, I could
handle it pretty easily when they steal it
from you.
And again, that's not easy.
And we have to fight.
We have no choice.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
That's what I alluded to before, which is
Trump just doesn't believe that he lost.
He says, if I lost, I would accept losing
and I would be fine.
I would be a big boy.
I would be an adult.
Well, but sir, this time, sir, sir, you're
not actually acting like an adult, but you
said you would.
Well, no, that's because I didn't actually
lose.
Oh, OK.
OK.
I mean, just completely disconnected.
And the crowd cheering is a real sign to us.
The fact that these crowds continue to believe
this tells us a lot about the state of the
Republican electorate at this point in time.
Then Trump, again, sort of alludes to the
idea that once these audits are done, he'll
be back in office.
And, of course, there's no mechanism for such
reinstatement.
And of course, the audits aren't real audits.
And of course, he didn't actually win.
And, you know, I don't think I need to tell
you, they
Speaker 2: almost got away with it.
They may have gotten away with it.
We're going to find out because something's
going to have to be done.
Something I don't think so.
You know, if somebody robs Tiffany, a beautiful
jewelry, 57th and fifth, good location, excellent
location, and they steal the diamonds and
then they get caught, they have to turn the
diamonds back.
The diamond is very simply amazing the way
it works.
Speaker 1: So apparently returning stolen
jewelry to Tiffany's at fifty seventh and
5th is equivalent to the reinstatement of
a president nine months post an election.
It's all very, very strange.
And you and I might say, David, who could
possibly believe that at this point, the people
in the crowd, at least some of them, seem
to believe it.
Check out what Donald Trump then claimed about
the first six months of Joe Biden's presidency.
But you know what?
Speaker 2: If instead of doing the harbor
this thing, it was the worst six months in
the history of the presidency.
I don't know that that's true.
But I would say it is.
But, you
Speaker 1: know, it's not true.
Trump's instinct there, I don't know if it's
true.
What's what's amazing to me about that is
all the people saying we've gone down a communist
spiral and it's all dystopian and it's all
terrible socialist, Marxist, etc.
Imagine being so disconnected from reality
that you believe Biden has even done that
much one way or the other.
I mean, quite frankly, many people, myself
included, wish that Joe Biden had done more.
Now, there might be people who would disagree
with the stuff Biden did if he did it and
people who would agree.
But he's just not done that much.
He did some executive orders right up front
to reverse some of the most atrocious things
that Donald Trump did.
He got covid stimulus passed, which was a
great thing, but it's relatively low hanging
fruit globally.
Europe looks at the controversy that took
place here over Biden's covid stimulus package,
which Republicans were against, despite signing
off right away on the Trump stimulus packages,
which were very, very similar.
He hasn't even done that much one way or the
other.
And the idea that in six months so much has
happened, aside from whether you like it,
that this would be the most significant anything,
six months of a presidency.
It's just imaginary.
And then Trump starts leaning more heavily
on the communist stuff.
Speaker 2: Like it or not, we are becoming
a communist country.
That's what's happening.
Speaker 1: I continue to recommend that when
people say that, say what is communist mean?
What can you define communism?
What exactly is a communist society and economy?
A government?
It's a really fun experiment because it goes
nowhere.
And then Donald Trump recommending the vaccine,
but also recommending freedom.
Speaker 2: We are at the beginning of a communist.
Radicals are seizing power and destroying
everything we hold dear as Americans.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's more on the communism
stuff.
Then Trump recommends the vaccine, but also
recommends freedom.
It's like, what does that mean?
I mean,
Speaker 2: how about the vaccine?
I came up with the vaccine.
They said it would take three to five years,
going to save the world.
I recommend you take it, but I also believe
in your freedoms.
One hundred percent.
But just so you understand.
But it was a great achievement
Speaker 1: and noticed the crowd is not cheering
for.
I recommend the vaccine.
The crowd is cheering for.
I recommend freedom.
And that's, you know, I recommend you take
it, but I also recommend freedom.
Yeah.
And the delusional nature of I came up with
the vaccine.
I mean, aside from the fact that, you know,
it's scientists and and people in medicine
who come up with the vaccine, the idea that
Trump did anything other than just pre purchased
some vaccines is laughable at this point.
It's crazy that he's even still repeating
that.
And then Trump finally gets to the topic of
running in twenty, twenty four.
And he says, you know, when when I talk about
people tell me running in 2024, I just won
an election, why do I need to run again?
Speaker 2: You're way ahead of everybody running.
Twenty four, sir.
You're going to win.
And I say, wait a minute, I just won six months
ago.
Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so Trump insisting run again,
I just won this thing.
As many of you know, the election, the Olympics
are going on.
And then Donald Trump started sort of goading
the audience into booing the U.S. women's
soccer team, which doesn't sound particularly
patriotic to me.
Speaker 2: To mention the U.S. women's soccer
team is a very good example of what's going
on.
Why, earlier this week, they unexpectedly
lost to Sweden three to nothing.
Speaker 1: And people are cheering the loss
of the U.S. women's.
I thought this was all about Team America,
the they're cheering that the U.S. women's
soccer team lost.
Speaker 2: Americans were happy about it.
Speaker 1: No, your crowd is happy about it,
dude.
They're cheering.
Speaker 2: You proved that point before I
even said it demented.
Speaker 1: OK, anyway, so so Trump almost
seeing people cheering it as a good thing.
I mean, what is considered patriotic about
that?
I thought this these were the people who had
the monopoly on patriotism.
Then in a bizarrely xenophobic moment, Trump
can't remember the name of a Taliban leader
and he just referred to him as Muhammad.
It's very strange.
Speaker 2: It's a much different to you.
I told the Taliban, I spoke to the leader
and I spoke.
I said, let's call him Muhammad.
I said, Muhammad, we're leaving.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So his name is actually he Baitullah Akhundzada.
But Trump absent remembering, he's like, well,
it's a Muslim guy.
Let's just call him Mohammed.
Bizarre moment.
And of course, like the implicit xenophobia
of that going completely over the crowd said
or not going over their head, but they like
it.
And then and this is really relevant to what's
going on within the party.
When the name Mike Pence is mentioned, the
crowd boos.
This is a Republican crowd.
Speaker 2: And I only wish that my friend
Mike Pence had that additional courage to
send to send the results back to the legislatures
because it all happened so quickly.
You know, they schemed in this plan for four
years.
This.
Right.
Speaker 1: So the crowd not liking the former
Republican president.
This is a Republican crowd, by the way.
And then lastly, it all coming full circle.
Trump describing a propaganda technique that
he's actually using to convince people of
stuff.
Speaker 2: But that's what they do.
And you know what it's called disinformation.
They make up a lot of crap and they say it
over and over and over.
And one day you say, oh, who is the one that
wanted to defund?
I guess it was the Republicans.
The Republicans are against a very serious.
Speaker 1: So anyway, Trump saying disinformation,
you repeat something often enough and people
start to believe it, which, of course, is
what he has done.
It's it's been his strategy.
I won.
I won massive vote.
So all this different stuff, that's the technique
that he uses.
He's identifying a known technique.
It's just he's attributing it to the other
side.
So what are the takeaways here?
First of all, completely outrageous, globally
humiliating speech.
I mean, the fact that a former president speaks
this way, he's doing these speeches is saying
these things is absolutely humiliating.
And in addition to that, in addition to that,
is the reality that he still mostly owns the
Republican Party.
The crowd is with him, although you have a
hand, you know, Liz Cheney, who is only with
Trump 90 percent of the time, says the election
stuff has to stop.
Adam Kinzinger, who's going to be on the House
January 6th commission that starts tomorrow,
he's willing to say Trump is wrong on a couple
of, but he mostly owns the Republican Party.
And so the question is, what happens in 22
with that and what happens in 24?
And I want to hear from you.
We'll have more coverage of this deranged
and demented speech on our Instagram at David
Pakman show.
You can leave your comments there or wherever
else you're watching or listening today.
Let me know your thoughts